our subject for this evening safe
but not secure
what did i say
safe
but not secure
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
after this there was a feast of the jews
and jesus went up to jerusalem
now there is at jerusalem by the sheep
market a pool
which is called in the hebrew tongue
bethesda
having five porches
in these lay a great multitude of
impotent fork of blind halt withered
waiting for the moving of the water
for an angel went down at a certain
season into the pool and troubled the
water
whosoever then first after the troubling
of the water stepped in was made whole
of whatsoever disease he had
and a certain man was there which had an
infirmity thirty and eight years
when jesus saw him lie
and knew he had been now a long time in
that case
jesus saith unto him
will thou be made whole
the impotent man answered him sir i have
no man when the water is troubled to put
me into the pool
but while i'm coming another steppeth
down before me
jesus said unto him rise
take up thy bed
and walk and immediately the man was
made whole and took up his bed and
walked and on the same day was the
sabbath
the jews therefore said unto him that
was cured it is the sabbath day it is
not lawful for thee to carry thy bed
he answered them
he that made me hold the same said unto
me take up thy bed and walk
then ask the him
what man is that which said unto thee
take up thy bed and walk
and he that was healed was not who it
was for jesus had conveyed himself away
a multitude being in that place
afterward
jesus finally in the temple
and said unto him
behold thou art made whole
sin
no more
lest a worse thing
come unto thee
god is good
and all the time
you know these words are very solemn
sin
no more
or something worse will come to you
when you receive light
follow it
are you following me
or something worse will befall you
if the light is indeed be darkness how
great is that darkness he also said that
to the woman in john 8 taking an
adultery
neither do i condemn thee go on sin no
more he said to a woman he said it to a
man go and sin no more it also tells us
based on his statement to the man in
john 5 14 there's a connection between
sickness and sin
it may not be any sin you've committed
while you're sick it may be just living
in a sinful world either way there is a
connection between sickness and sin
that's why the bible tells us in psalm
103 verse 3 who forgiveth all thine
iniquities who healeth
all thy diseases
exodus 15 26
if thou will diligently hearken unto the
voice of the law of thy god
and will do that which is right in his
sight i will give ear to his
commandments and keep all his statutes
give me one word for all of that
obey
i will put none of these diseases upon
you
which i have brought
upon the egyptians
for i am the lord
that he lived thee
let the words of christ to that man be
to us today because the words live
forever and that man is dead
sin
no more
lest the worst thing
come unto thee and the worst thing that
can be is to be struck out of god's
group that will make it into the kingdom
when he comes
well you're not smiling so i might have
depressed you
how are you
it's nice to see you
it really is i was praying for you today
i do
asking god to bless you and make you a
blessing it has to work both ways you
see when god called abraham he said thou
shalt be a blessing and in thee shall
all families of the earth be blessed the
office where you work should be blessed
because of your presence
let me say differently your presence at
work
should reduce hostility
and backbiting
and in fighting
you should represent an eosis of peace
in the desert of dissension
or in a school room
or where or in the church board come on
say amen
you should not be identified as a
consistent troublemaker on the church
board so when you're sick and can't
attend people start giving thanksgiving
to god
be a peacemaker
at all times blessed are the
peacemakers for they shall be called
the children of god it's nice to see i
said that those of you online thank you
very much for joining us it is 7 11
precisely i'll release you before 8
o'clock
i believe in keeping things short i
haven't always done that but i am trying
recently to keep the presentations short
is there anyone with us tonight you are
not a seventh-day adventist you are here
for the first time nice your hand first
time
all right i believe we have some guests
online wherever you are our guests our
friends god bless you
thank you so much
for joining us we hope that god will
touch you very individually as he
touches us through his divine word which
has the power to create
physically and to recreate spiritually
i had a good day thanks for asking
and i thank god
for that
why are you laughing nobody asked me so
i had to say
but it was in your heart to ask so you
are innocent as a goose okay
our subject for this evening safe
but not secure
what did i say
safe
but not secure
when we go to bed at night we lock our
doors is that right
do thieves still break in
yes
there's no system that can keep out a
determined thief
are you with me whether it's a bank
or whatever
we are safe in our homes yes but are we
absolutely secure the answer is no a
plane can fall out of the sky and land
on your house
that happens from time to time the most
recent i think was in san diego a few
weeks ago a plane fell out of the sky
and landed on a house
we are safe and we thank god for that
but are we secure
before i get into that message please
remember preserve reverence as you have
been doing god bless you for that track
record you've established i'm personally
grateful to you because disturbance
disturbs me
and you have not been guilty of that
thank you very much
fave enough make sure these things are
turned off as is my custom my habit my
tradition
let me check mine it looks off
hope it doesn't surprise me
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord what
put your words in that man's mouth and
god knows every time i say that i mean
it i want god's words in my mouth i
really do i do not want to be
responsible for consciously or
unconsciously misleading anyone when god
told the destroying angels in ezekiel
chapter 9
to go in after him him being the one
with the putting the mark on people's
heads
and smite
and god told that destroying angels
begin at my sanctuary begin with the
leaders begin with the preachers
are you following what i'm trying to say
i don't want to be among them so i ask
god all the time
put your words in my mouth
so that those who listen
may be safe and secure
because the truth secures us
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth
favor number three think as you listen
uh isaiah 1 18 come now
i love that invitation god is pleading
he said come now let us reason together
saith the lord let's pray
our father
our god
we thank you for your everlasting love
we thank you god for your mercy that
still lingers
we thank you for christ
we thank you for his sacrifice
his ongoing intercession now
we thank you to god for the constant
conviction and guidance of your spirit
we thank you father for the protection
of mighty angels unseen but always
present
if we have sinned against you
forgive us dear god
we're sorry
and we ask you father to put into our
hearts as you promised in genesis 3 15
put enmity in us against the enemy
father i humble myself before you
i am human i am dirt clay earth
help me their god stand with me stand in
me and literally speak through me
suppress my carnal nature they god
that my overriding interest is your
glory and your glory alone
bless those who listening online we
thank you for their constant presence
wherever they are their god bless them
take care of them father in this time of
restrictions owing to this pandemic
bless all the governments represented by
those listening father
particularly our government a god
give wisdom to these men and women that
they may make decisions that allow your
church to do its work
father bless the sick
relieve suffering their god
whether people follow you or not just
relieve suffering
remove covet 19 from anyone who has
contracted it but begin with members of
the household of faith
and as i often say to you god right now
as i pray someone somewhere
is suffering
someone somewhere is about to lose his
or her life in the most violent way in
the name of jesus their god
deliver some people
just to stop suffering
now speak to me father that i may be a
blessing to your people
i pray from my heart in jesus name let
god's people say with me
amen and amen
go with me to revelation chapter 12.
we'll read from verse 9
16 after seven
thank you for the music i don't see the
sister who played so well
oh there you are and my thanks to all
those who worship god in song and music
night after night god bless you i really
really mean that god bless you very very
much may god continue to bless those
operating the machinery upstairs
downstairs whoever
rojos whatever your contribution is
may god bless you for contributing to
the smooth running of this series of
meetings what book did i say
what chapter
reading from verse seven
very familiar passage
the bible says and there was war in
heaven
michael and his angels fought against a
dragon and the dragon fought and his
angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found any more
in heaven
and the great dragon was cast out
not all serpent called the devil and
satan which deceiveth the whole world
finished that verse for me he was cast
out into the earth come on
and his angels were cast out with him
question
how was it possible
that perfect angels
were thrown out of heaven after they
rebelled
yes sin
but how is it possible
for perfect angels to sin
i want you to consider this
the angels
were still
under probation
someone who passes probation
cannot be lost
and if the person passes probation
negatively cannot be saved
let me say differently
the angels in heaven had not yet been
made secure
after having passed a probationary
period when god made angels and he made
them just by speaking
angels were not made from dirt they were
made just by the voice of god
psalm 148 1215. no need to go there
praise he the lord
praise you the lord from the heavens
praise him in the heights praising him
all his angels praising him all his
hosts verse 5 let them praise the name
of the lord for he commanded and they
were created god just spoke and angels
came
having made them
god put them on probation
why because they did not ask to be
created
are you with me
god wants worship that is what
voluntary
they were not made voluntarily they were
made at god's will now god allows them a
period to demonstrate the desire to
continue in that happy estate
that period had not yet passed when
lucifer entered upon his rebellion and
some of them went with him and they were
thrown out conflict and courage page 15
paragraph 3 the servant of the lord
writes like the angels the dwellers in
eden had been placed upon probation
the angels were on probation that's why
some of them fell of course the
probation now is secured the angels in
heaven can no longer fall and those who
fell cannot get back
are you following me
now let's leave heaven and come down
adam and eve they were made
sinless
perfect
in the image of god and of course they
had to develop that image more and more
as they lived
they sinned
and were put out
what does that tell you
their probation
they had failed
the probation
they failed probation is a period of
time to meet certain conditions
to put it very simply adam and eve did
not
so they were put out had they passed the
probationary period they would have been
made secure
and never could have fallen to the enemy
let me say it again have they survived
survive is not a good word have they
passed the period of probation the test
they would have been made secure by god
and the possibility of sin would have
been removed
they fell they did not pass
the probationary period
and so they were put out
god is a god
who gives people a period of time to do
what is right
that period of time is not forever it is
limited
and the length of time god gives varies
from person to person on nation to
nation
we're discussing safe but not secure
we're looking at probation
and this world is under probation right
now even at the secular level you know
dependen uh the the prison system they
have probation
you may hire someone and the person is
on probation work for six months and if
you pass you meet certain standards we
will hire you permanently and give you
health insurance
but for the first six months you're just
on probation you have no benefits
demonstrate to us what you can do when
you've done that successfully you're
secure
in universities professors
they they covet tenure
you know what tenure is
virtually you're hired for life
unless you do something truly horrendous
but under normal circumstances when
you're tenured you are there for life
that's why it is so difficult to get are
you following me and professors they try
they try they oh
you have five years to produce research
material
that impresses your committee and if
they impress you're granted tenure but
tenure is a probationary period i mean
the the process to tenure if you're not
granted almost always you have to leave
that institution
so we understand
probation
let's go to genesis 6.
our subject's safe
but not secure
genesis 6.
we read from verse 1.
you have genesis 6 reading from verse 1
i read from the king james version of
the bible again i'm happy to see my
young brothers and my little sisters in
the church i really am i'm always happy
to see you god bless you for loving the
lord
and for loving his work
when i was your age i was also in church
faithfully
and so i love to see young boys and
young girls i also love to see men in
church
let me digress briefly before we get to
genesis 6.
most prison systems are overrun by men
the devil knows remove men
and society cannot be as strong as it
ought to be
remove them from the family
remove them from the church remove men
and put them in prisons
and see the effect
on society
most churches
the bulk of the population of churches
is made up of women and we thank god for
the ladies don't misunderstand me i'm
not complaining about the ladies in
church i'm complaining about the absence
of men
so men brothers god bless you
and may your faithfulness attract other
men to jesus christ coming to christ is
not a sign of weakness it is the highest
sign of intelligence
and we need more men to come to church
i read somewhere
maybe 80 or 85 percent of inmates come
from
single parent families
by that i mean almost always no men
and so they have they have no models
and so this athlete tries to be a model
and this one tries to be a mod the ideal
model for a man should be your father
and so men
god bless you
stay faithful and i'm sure by your
faithfulness other men will be drawn to
christ let me pray again father as i
continue to god please speak through me
i pray in jesus name amen
genesis 6 reading from verse one it came
to pass
when men began to multiply on the face
of the earth
and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of god saw the daughters
of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose now read with me and the lord
said what
my spirit shall not always strive with
man for that he also is flesh finish the
verse yet his day shall be a hundred and
twenty years
notice his day shall be 120 years in
prophecy a day is a year all right
my spirit
shall not always strive with man
what does that tell us it's very solid
there comes a point
when god's spirit stops bleeding
perhaps i can say differently there
comes a point when the breathing of the
spirit is no longer detected by the
heart and soul
because when you say no to god once it
becomes easier to say no the second time
and every expression of no
makes it more difficult for you to hear
the voice as the spirit of god tries and
pleads and appeals
the soul becomes deadened
and it's not god's fault my spirit shall
not always stride with man
for that he also is flesh yet his day
shall be 120 years
god gave the antediluvians in the days
of noah a hundred and twenty years
to repent
it's remarkable to consider that if they
had repented
what would have happened
there would have been no flood
there would have been
no flood
noah preached and preached
and preached the longest crusade you can
imagine
while he was building the ark
eight people who were alive
when the reigns came
into the dark eight
and they were all
his family
let me digress again
if the entire world is lost
let me talk to the men
get your family into the earth
that amen didn't have much life
if when christ comes
the whole world is lost be sure you're
leading your family into that ark the
coming of
christ god bless noah
he took his whole family with him
the pleadings of god
occur over a limited period of time
when
the 120 years expired
god shut the door of the ark
genesis 7 16 and the lord shut him in
now i told you safe and secure
we'll take this event and we'll try to
apply it on a broader scale when god
shut the door noah did not shut the door
an angel shut that door
but the angel working for god god shut
the door
two things happened immediately
those on the outside talk to me
couldn't get in
those on the inside
couldn't get out
not even if they wanted to the door was
shot by god
are you following me
now they were secure from the flood
those on the outside lost safety and
security there is something inevitable
about the close of a probationary period
what do i mean by that
it cannot be reversed
let me say differently
when god closes probation he does not
reopen it
that door was opened when everyone on
earth was
dead
and god opened it
or instructed noah
then no on his family came out
to start life on earth all over again
that's why the bible says to noah in
genesis 9 1 be fruitful and multiply
repentance the earth exactly what he
said to adam
so in that sense noah is a second atom
when that door closed
those on the outside could not get in
but you'll observe
the door was shut and seven days passed
before the rains came
the flood was upon the earth and the
rain the
seven days passed before the rain came i
should say
what was going on in noah's mind in the
ark what was going on in the minds and
the hearts and the of those outside they
were laughing perhaps making fun
throwing stones that they are because
the door shut probation closed but they
were still alive for a while
let me scare you a little bit
there are people in churches
whose probation has already closed
but they're still coming to church
driven by the force of habit
maybe i should not have said let me
scare you let me
cause you to reflect
deeply
listen to these words
patriarchs and prophets page 140
paragraph one
every day
the probation of some is closing
every hour some are passing beyond the
reach of mercy
right now as i speak someone somewhere
around the world is having his or her
probationary period end
and once that ends
it is never reopened
if it ends positively the person's
secure sealed if it ends negatively the
person has no more opportunity to come
to christ christ closes probation or the
father does when the father sees you
have had all the opportunity you need
now if god is not willing to then he
should perish it must be a very painful
thing for god to close somebody's
probation
because he knows that soul is lost
forever
so the angel closed the door of the ark
seven days went by
then the rains came
in that seven day period
repentance was impossible you can speak
the words but nothing would happen once
probation closes there is no such thing
as repentance go with me to revelation
chapter 8.
look at the work of the high priest
interceding on behalf of his people
revelation eight will read from verse
two
well from verse 3 of revelation 8.
and another angel came and did what
stood at the altar having a golden
censer and there was given to him much
incense that he offered with the prayer
of the saints upon the golden altar
which was before the throne and the
smoke of the incense which came with the
prayer of the saints ascended up before
god out of the angel's hand this is the
high priest interceding who's our high
priest jesus christ
interceding for us now
read verse 5 for me what does that say
and the angel took the censor and
filled it with what
fire from the altar and
cast it into the earth paul what is that
symbolizing
the end of intercession
which is another thing
the close
of probation
that's it for the earth
my listening friends
when god
sees
that there's nothing else you can do
to save a person
or a nation
he closes probation go with me to daniel
chapter 24.
daniel not 24 sorry
daniel chapter 9 verse 24 did i say
chapter 24
all right that's because you're not
praying for me daniel 9
reading from verse 24 all good
adventists know this passage
do you have it daniel 9 24
it's 7 34
reading daniel 9 24.
when you found it say amen
70 weeks are determined upon thy people
and upon thy holy city now determine
means cut off
it's a period allotted to you 70. and
that's taken from the 2300 days
mentioned in daniel 8 14 in the previous
chapter which daniel did not fully
understand the angel explained the the
ram with two horns he explained the goat
the notable horn he explained the horn
being broken into four he explained the
little one that comes out of one of the
four he explains all of that
daniel does not understand the 2300 days
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed and
so the very last verse of chapter 8
daniel said none understood the vision
he fainted he was sick for several days
then he rose did the king's business but
no one understood the vision
in chapter 9 the angel comes back
because god wants us to understand by
the way the same way god sent an angel
to explain to daniel and an angel to
explain to john god is willing to send
an angel to help you
seventy weeks are determined upon thy
people
and upon thy holy city
to finish the transgression
to make an end of sin
to make reconciliation for iniquity
to bring in everlasting righteousness to
seal up the vision and prophecy and
tonight the most holy
these are things god required of his
people back then he gave them 70 years
prophetically speaking
490 that began in 457 bc and ended when
34 a.d
bc
3480 marked the end of that 70-year
period that god it was a probationary
period
now god had borne along with the
israelites hundreds of years before that
and they never ever did what god would
have them to do god finally came to the
point he gave them a probationary period
70 weeks are determined upon by people
at the end of it
god left moved another direction
regarding a special people
still jews but this time spiritual jews
are you following me
thy house is left unto thee
desolate
christ was gone
from a people not from individuals
within that nation are you following me
let me say that again
he he they were rejected as a nation but
individuals could still come to him is
that clear say amen
when um
noah pronounced the curse
on canaan
elohim makes it clear
that why there was a curse on the
canaanites god gave them hundreds of
years to live differently
they could have come to him individually
so a curse on a nation does not preclude
an individual from coming to god
i wanted you to say god had a
probationary period for a nation
he had a probationary period for the
entire world in the days of noah
now how close are you and i
to the close of probation
now i said
that
individuals have their probation closed
every day
well the servant of the lord said that
every hour right now someone's probation
is closing but there's also such a thing
as a global general closure probation
which will mark at the beginning of the
falling of the what
the plagues
which i hope to deal with this week
how close are we to that
all right
let's go to revelation 6.
revelation 6 is 738 our subject's safe
but not secure
when our probation
closes on the positive side
we'll be absolutely secure he that is
just he is holy let him be holy sil it
is righteous let him be righteous still
but right now we're safe if we're in
christ but the possibility of leaving
christ still exists
before i get to uh revelation 6 let me
get this in
go to second timothy 4. i need to say
this
ii timothy chapter 4.
let's read
verse
10.
you have second timothy 4 verse 10
i mean the god of heaven and earth
continue to speak through me and grant
me that humility of spirit to listen to
the spirit as he speaks to me
read with me but
ii timothy 4 verse 10
dimas
hath forsaken me having loved this
present world and is departed unto
thessalonica what is paul saying one of
his workers who worked with him changed
and left him
having he loved this present world
when he was with paul serving god
faithfully he was safe
are you following me
but not secure
because the possibility of apostasizing
still existed are you with me
are you sure
so when i say secure i mean no more
possibility of leaving god you're sealed
that's what i mean by secure
right now
we're safe
now i can't say if someone's probation
is closed or not i can't say that i'm
not god
if it is i hope it is closed in the
right direction are you following me if
it applies to me i hope it's the same
thing
but demas
left paul
went off into the world
lost his safety and surely had no
security now let's go to the seven seals
revelation six
how many seals are there i just told you
there's seven seals
okay
six seals and revelation six then we
have the intervening chapter revelation
7 that produces or introduces those who
will stand when the terrible times come
with the coming of jesus christ
revelation 6 the last verse ends is
where who shall be able to stand
for the day of his wrath has come and
who shall be able to stand revelation 7
tells us who shall be able to stand
those who are what give me one word
sealed
revelation has
frightening news and then good news
frightening news some good news to keep
you going frightening news some good
news to keep you going read revelation
13 this beast
first one to ten then this other beast
you know 11 to 18. but 14 begins with
144 000 having his father's name then we
go to six the three angels messages and
the terrible message of revelation 14
verse 9 through 11. so this is
frightening news some good news
frightening news some good news the six
seals frightening news
the history of the church spiritually
the first seal
normally dated between
31 the death of christ and 100. that's
the white horse when the church was
pure
the doctrines were fairly
were very reliable i should say
no real impurities even though the
spirit of iniquity had already begun to
work in the times of paul
the second seal
the red horse we go from white to red
about 100 to 313 when constantine joined
the church joined the church
and persecution had begun on a much
larger scale
then he ended it with an edict
then the the third horse which is black
from 3 13 to 5 38 the period when the
papal power was building up to becoming
a truly truly truly intimidating force
with civil and religious power then the
fourth the pale horse with death and
hell riding with him 5 38 some say to
about 70 98 sunday to 5 7 15 17 when the
reformation began
then the next one 15 17 to about 1755
when
the signs mentioned on the sixth seal
began to occur let's go to revelation 6
let's read from verse 12. look at those
signs
is 742 how close are we to the closer
probation
yes we are
let the bible give us some hints are you
at revelation 7 12.
read with me and i beheld when you had
opened the sixth seal on law there was
what
a great earthquake when did that occur
according to adventist teaching
well not according to adventist teaching
but when did it occur
1755 the great lisbon earthquake it is
said the earthquake affected an area of
over four
million square miles
four
and the sun became black of sac clothes
hair and the moon became as blood when
did that happen
the dark day
may
19. 17
and that happened in new england area
darkness darkness darkness and the
following night the moon became as blood
and this is documented
now
and the stars of heaven fell into the
earth even as a fig tree casted her in
timely figs when she's shaking of a
mighty wind verse 13 when did that
happen
there's november 13 i believe it is 1833
and there was a meteoric shower all over
north america
it is said it was seen in mexico
parts of the caribbean
a shower that continued for hours
hours
until the sun rose
and the brightness of the sand blotted
out a meteoric shower such as the world
had never seen
these occurred
under the sixth scene
and the last event was 1833
november 13.
now go to verse 14 of revelation 6. our
subject's safe but not secure what does
that say
and the heavens departed as a scroll
come on
when did this roll together and every
mountain and island were what moved out
of their place now that has not yet
happened
that has not yet happened those are
events that will occur just before jesus
comes when the world is in turmoil
now this is not symbolic language
are you with me
a lot of revelations symbolic
and every mountain and island will move
out of their places that will literally
happen
so we're between
verse 13
and verse 14.
now the last clear sign
the falling of the stars was 1833.
you count how many years that has been
you have 100 years 1933 then you have 67
and 21
or 200 something years since then that
tells you now how close we are
to the heavens departed as a scroll when
it is rolled together and every mountain
and island will move out of the places
there will be disruption on this earth
just before jesus comes in because
probation would have been closed
remember the priest or the angel
representing the high priest takes the
sensor with fire
not incense just fire
go back to revelation 8 quickly you look
at me strangely
revelation 8 let's read verse 3.
i said it had fire when he threw it on
the earth not incense revelation 8 3
what does that say
and another angel came and stood at the
altar having a golden censer and they
was given to him what
much instance now you should offer it
with a prayer of the saints upon the
what golden altar which was before the
throne
it hadn't much incense representing the
merits of jesus christ
no prayer is accepted by the father if
it is not mingled with the merits of
jesus christ no man can come unto the
father but by me
but if you read
verse 5 read it for me now and the angel
took the censor and
not with incense
why
intercession is done
what does god use fire to do
destroy purify cleanse destroy he casts
us into the earth work is done
that's when we'll experience
the heavens departing as a scroll
mountains moving
catastrophe
jeremiah saw that
a part of it he said i beheld the earth
and behold it was without form and void
he uses language we find in genesis
chapter 1 verse 2.
that's what is just down the road
awaiting us
which means
we are close
to the close
of probation
my brothers and sisters let me ask you
in this building and online
how much longer
must god give us to come to him
listen to god pleading with israel go to
isaiah 1 very quickly isaiah 1.
we read from verse 15.
isaiah 1 reading from verse 15 our
subjects safe but not secure and by
security i mean that state of safety
after probation is closed and those who
are holy are holy still and there can be
no change after that but those who lost
are lost as well no change after that
isaiah 1 let's read from verse 15.
and when you spread for your hands i
will do what
hi my night meaning when you lift your
hands in prayer i will hide my eyes from
you yeah when you make many prayers come
on i will not hear why
your hands are full of blood
those are god's people
he is not addressing the assyrians
he's addressing the
islam
verse 6 stain what does that say
wash you come on
stop stop stop
wash you
make you clean
the work of cleansing requires
cooperation from us with god
are you following me
so god tells them
wash you make you clean put away the
evil of your doings from before mine
eyes listen to me god will not take the
cigarettes out of your pocket
you will not take the drugs out of your
whatever he will not take whatever the
condom from your wallet he said but you
put it away
act
put away the evil of your doings from
before mine eyes
read the last of that verse
come on read the last three words or
four
cease to do evil
now look at the first statement in verse
17.
learn to do well
my brothers my sisters god is saying to
you and to me
cease
to do stop
what you're doing
let me tell you with great brotherly
love
the sins i don't conquer
will conquer me
salvation isn't a one-man performance in
the sense that god doesn't care how we
feel about it no no no
you sister do evil you wash you you make
you clean you put away the evil of your
doings from before mine eyes yes i'll
help you but you've got to demonstrate i
am sick and tired of a life of sin
always drunk you know full of smoke full
of drugs full of whatever i am tired of
that life i choose jesus
because one day
listen to these words
god grants
to people
a period
of probation
but there is a point beyond which divine
patience is exhausted
and the judgments of god
are sure to follow
what am i saying
yes there's a probation that will close
for the entire world
but let's take our minds off the world
for a minute
there's one that closes for you
when saul disobeyed god
god said because thou has rejected the
word of the lord he hath also rejected
thee
and the first samuel 16 verse 14 the
bible says and the spirit of the lord
departed from saul
and an evil spirit from the lord
troubled him
let me clear that up quickly an evil
spirit from the lord simply means god
allowed an evil spirit you see there's
no vacuum in nature physically or
spiritually if the spirit of god goes
finish my words
an evil spirit comes
god loves it
the bible says the spirit of the lord
left saul
and god had chosen saul
that was it
go to john 13
751 our subject safe but not secure
we're absolutely secure when we're
sealed and there's no possibility of
going back
but we're safe now
it puzzles me how people leave the
church i just don't understand it
what book did i say john what chapter
13.
let's read for verse 18.
are you there
i speak not of you all
i know whom i have chosen but that the
scripture may be fulfilled finish the
verse
he that eateth bread with me hath lifted
up his heel against me which means
deceive me betray me to whom is jesus
speaking
judas now i'm sure he didn't look him in
the eye and say that but he's talking to
all 12 disciples gathered for the last
supper and the foot washing he said he
that eateth bread with me have lifted up
it was a fulfillment of psalm 41 verse
9. but jesus drops a clue
what is he trying to get judas to do
repent
go to verse 21
when jesus had thus said he was troubled
in spirit and testified and said what
verily verily i say unto you that one of
you shall betray me now he gives another
clue
why he does not want judas to do what go
through with this hellish plan
because he loved him
and he said himself god sent not his son
into the world to condemn the world but
other worlds through him i be saved
christ came to save and here is this man
refusing salvation
then peter said to john ask him who it
is
verse 25 john said who is it lord who is
it
jesus answered he it is to whom i shall
give the soap when i have dipped it
and when you dip this up finish that
first he gave it to judas iscariot the
son of simon now read the next verse for
me
satan entered him
what did jesus say
that thou doest what happened at that
point
over
done
did jesus try yes or no yes
he tried
now the bible says
jesus christ the same
yesterday come on today and forever how
did he handle the original devil
same way god bless you same way he must
have given lucifer
chances
chances and finally lucifer's probation
why do i say the original devil because
jesus said in john 6 70 have i not
chosen you 12 one of you is a devil
and the devil is the devil is the devil
are you following me
and so the way he handled one devil on
earth gives us insight into how he
handled the original devil because
christ is the same yesterday today and
forever he must have given lucifer
opportunities to turn back
then his probation closed
thrown
out
my brothers and sisters
your interest in god's word tells me
the doors of mercy are still open
your constant press suggests to me that
those if you're troubled if you're
concerned about your relationship with
god it is clear evidence that the spirit
of god is still with you but god said he
will not always strive
those of you online
those of you in person
is christ
calling you
to leave a life of sin
answer him
and come
come into the
ark you don't have to move a muscle you
come up here
give that life to christ
when he comes
and you see what will happen to this
earth
you will be glad
but give it to him
because that's what he wants
and we're supposed to do what god likes
so jesus said he that have sent me is
with me the father hath not left me
alone for i do always those things that
please him what pleases god to save a
soul do what brings god pleasure give
your life to him
recommit your life to god
let him hold you
because one day
probation
will close
for the world at large
but it closes daily for different people
how many of you say father
i recommit my life to you as fully as i
know how can i see your right hand
stand up with me
you know there's him i like
jesus saves jesus saves you know that
him that's what he specializes in
can i go to five after eight
can i
christ is still human
right now
he took his humanity with him glorified
humanity of course
and that's the body we will have
philippians 3 20 21 we'll have the same
body with the heroes
but
it still tells me that in order to save
us there had to be a change in the
composition of the godhead
are you with me
before christ became human there were
three spirits
now one is a human
not an angel a human
there is someone in the garden who looks
like you
but that's a price that had to be paid
it's a price
now when christ rose from the dead and
the disciples thought he was a ghost he
showed them his hands
his side his feet what was he showing
them the marks of the crucifixion he
still has them
so we have a scarred god
forever
and you and i will we will not have a
pimple
not a zit
are you following me
jesus christ
for eternity
will have the marks
that's love
that's identifying with someone
i am one with you
come
come to me
because when you come to christ and
you're in christ
you sit where christ sits now where's
that on the right hand of god
no angel sits there
because christ didn't die on calvary to
save angels
he died to save us
there will be a vacancy in the heart of
god for all eternity
the same way there can be scars on
christ eternally said they shine like
jewels but still scars
the same way his humanity will be
carried throughout eternity throughout
eternity there will be vacancies in the
heart of god representing those who
could have been saved but refused
let not god have a vacancy in his heart
that was a space he had for you
occupy that space through faith now
please
my friends online i'm speaking to you
head bowed eyes closed
our father in heaven we thank you for
your patience
we thank you for probation day god but
we also thank you for the solemn reality
that probation does not last forever
but father
give us the reassurance that when we are
in christ
we need not worry
because the person in christ cannot be
lost
we recommend our lives today god
we really do as far as we can
take us father
and do with us as you will we give you
permission
there's someone listening to me father
in the building online who needs to come
back to jesus christ please the god
trouble that person give that person a
rest until he or she makes that
surrender
give the person the strength to leave
whatever is binding the person to the
world give the person that strength
bring him or her under the safety of
your wings
father in heaven
hear this humble pray god
let us live every day as if it is
literally our last
because none of us has a
guarantee of life tomorrow
thank you for bearing so long with us
god
thank you for tolerating not agreeing
with but tolerating all the abuse we've
done to you
and still loving us
let's leave this place to god determined
to stay safe with jesus
then when he comes
we might be secure with him
i pray for my heart in jesus name let
god's people say amen and amen god bless
you travel safely keep the speed limit
and i will see you tomorrow evening